foreign
[Music]
and welcome to today's webinar avoiding
common pitfalls in Laboratory Testing
for providers and laboratorians I am
Sabrina lemus of lab roots and I'll be
your moderator for today's event today's
educational web seminar is presented by
labroots and brought to you by
radiometer to learn more visit
radiometer.com
we encourage you to participate today by
submitting any questions you may have
during the presentation to do so simply
type them into the ask a question box
and click Send we'll answer as many
questions as we have time for at the end
of the presentation you may also submit
any technical issues here as well if you
have trouble seeing or hearing the
presentation
this webinar is educational and thus
offers free continuing education credits
please click on the continuing education
window at the bottom of your screen to
obtain your credits I'd now like to
welcome our speaker Joe m l Corey
associate professor of laboratory
medicine at Yale School of Medicine Joe
welcome you may now begin your
presentation
thank you Sabrina good morning good
afternoon and good evening to all of you
whatever you may be in the world it is
my pleasure to be talking to you today
about avoiding common pitfalls and
Laboratory Testing for providers and
laboratorians the goal from designing
this educational session was for me to
get Laboratories and providers together
to address these issues that can arise
when ordering or performing testing that
require both of us really to work
together to address them and before we
begin the session I'd like to disclose
that I am receiving an honorarium for
lab from Rob roots for giving the stock
I'm also a consultant for Siemens Health
engineers and aecc I'm on the board of
directors but I will not be discussing
any of their products and also as
already mentioned this webinar is
sponsored by radiometer
I would also like to mention that I am
available on YouTube as well so if you
like the educational content you see
here you can access them on YouTube I'm
creating videos I only have three so far
but for working up to make more of these
videos that focus on best lab recording
medicine practice and for today's talk
specifically we're going to be focusing
again on common pitfalls and laboratory
to test things specifically looking at
clinical chemistry testing which is my
area of specialty and then identifying
some solutions that we can Implement to
reduce the risk of these happening and
this will require again cooperation from
providers and laboratory professionals
but before we begin I'd like to get a
sense of you know the audience who you
are are you a healthcare provider who
orders Library tests frequently are you
a laboratory Who's involved in providing
these services or are you a student
simply interested in learning about this
topic so please start by answering this
question by clicking on the poll so I
can get a sense of who the audience is
being a lot of results coming in so
we'll give this another 20 seconds
all right and to keep this moving I
noticed the majority of our laboratory
professionals with a few Healthcare
Providers and a few students so I'm
going to push the results so you can all
see them and we'll keep moving forward
so I have six cases to present to you
today and I've saved the best for last
which is about hemolysis so that is a
pretty common one that we'll be
addressing at the end of the session but
beginning with other common conditions
that we see one of the more common ones
is unexplained hyperkalemia commonly
referred to as pseudo hypocharenia when
it's a false elevation and results so
this one we see on both the provider
side or the laboratory side then
basically it occurs like this when a
patient shows up in this case it's a 61
year old man admitted to emergency
medicine for an increased potassium
concentration of 6.3 the reference
interval for that lab is 3.5 to 5 and
that was discovered in annual checkup
so physical examination was not
consistent with it you did not feel any
symptoms that was associated with
hyperkalemia and when the patient was
brought back into the Ed and tested they
had a new result which was drawn in the
hospital that was 3.7
so I asked you know what could be
causing this and how often do you see it
in your laboratory or clinic so what's
also puzzling here is that specifically
unique for this patient is that they
were you know this is the third time
this happens to them when they go to the
Ed because they had a test that was
performed in an outpatient setting that
was an elevated uh potassium another
thing to notice was this always happened
that the annual checkup in January
and again a month later when the patient
was referred to an internist the same
thing happened another potassium was
elevated at 6.6 that came back normal
when the patient was admitted to the Ed
and a blood blood sample was drawn in
the hospital and tested
so what's more puzzling was also that
the patient wasn't using any medication
but his sister who also was admitted a
year ago to for the same problem she had
a potassium of 7.9 that could not be
confirmed any other blood sample so
clearly there is something that's
happening that's a bit also unique with
this family but typically when you know
in the laboratory when we see the see
this we activate our pseudo hyperkalemia
investigation so we start asking what
could be causing this and more commonly
you might be seeing these things with
hemolysis which typically for the labs
today they usually detect those by
measuring hemolysis index and stop those
results from being released so hemolysis
is really no longer the common reason to
get a high potassium result that's
released to the patient charge because
no slabs detect that and do not release
those results so in this case it was
released the other thing to note
sometimes during collection if there's a
delay in analysis that can also happen
but in this case the sample was
collected at around 8 and 9 A.M received
in the central lab by noon so that's not
a significant delay for testing
potassium typically you'd see that you
know you may see some slight elevations
but not certainly not something that's
like seven to eight multimoles per liter
which is way above critical
also these were collected in lithium
hepatine tubes that were centrifuged in
the lab so sometimes this can be you can
see some effects if you draw a serum
Sample versus a plasma sample so it's
helpful to know this and then the other
key factor here is the outside
temperatures uh varied between 34 to 43
degrees Fahrenheit
if you're outside of the US that's
pretty cold around you know two to five
degrees Celsius so it's almost freezing
temperature so pretty cold and that can
indicate a clue there something could be
happening with Transportation so what is
causing this is the part we need to deal
with so looking physiologically at how
potassium is maintained in plasma and
Sedum it's basically thanks to a
function of a of the sodium potassium
bomb that continuously pumps sodium
outside of the cell against the screen
and then it pumps potassium inside the
cell so you're basically maintaining
that homeostasis by pushing potassium
against its gradient inside the cell to
increase the concentration of potassium
inside the cell and increase the
concentration of sodium outside the cell
Downstream of that you have what we call
leak channels so these passively leak uh
sodium and potassium in the opposite
direction so it's it's a way to keep
that balance as well however under
extreme cold temperatures uh the sodium
potassium pump is inactivated and what
that means is that now the leak Channel
dominates and you have significant
release of potassium outside of the cell
and significant input of sodium inside
the cell they go one to one so it is not
a problem for most patients who are
healthy where if you leave the sample
you know for a few hours outside in the
cold or put it in the refrigerator that
mechanism will not have a significant
effect over uh a couple of hours however
in some patients with a specific
mutation of called the ABC B6 Gene that
leak channel is modified to an extent
where that leak is much more significant
so when the sodium potassium pump stops
working because that sample is
experiencing cold conditions that the
amount of potassium leak is much much
more significant and actually the
authors tested this and in recruited
healthy volunteers and patients with now
what we call familial pseudohypokalemia
that is that condition because it
depends on a genetic mutation that can
affect the family like in this case our
patient and his sister
healthy volunteers over a couple of
hours did not experience significant
increases in potassium when the sample
was exposed to different temperature
conditions you're seeing 20 degrees
Celsius all the way down to six degrees
Celsius you did not increase more than
20 percent over two hours however in
patients specifically with this gene
mutation you know even temperature
exposures for uh you know like an hour
you would basically over 50 if you're at
cold temperature so by two out to three
hours you're over 100 increase in the
Thousand so you're effectively bubbling
your potassium concentration so it's
very important then for these patients
that you don't delay the sample or
figure out a way to analyze it uh or
separate it quickly and also when people
don't talk about this but you know you
also see an equivalent decrease in
sodium which is noted in this the second
two graphs even healthy volunteers and
these patients but again in healthy
volunteers it's not significant you're
seeing these white boxes go down this
designates the decrease in sodium and
the increase in potassium is on the
upper end however because it's one to
one and because the reference interval
for sodium is so large that the change
of five millimoles per liter after two
hours that you may see in these patients
is not significant looking at the
reference interval of 1 4 like 135 to
145 for sodium so you're going from a
140 to 135 it's still pretty normal so
you don't really typically look at these
investigations or look at these patients
and worry so much about
pseudo-hypokalemia uh hyponatremia but
it does happen just just to point it out
so how can we solve this what are the
recommendations from this case really
it's very important that you centrifuge
the samples as soon as possible and
before transporting them to the central
lab so for all of our clinics that send
us samples from the outside
all of them typically uh spin the
samples before they store them outside
in the lock boxes and then send them to
the lab and that's important because
once you separate uh the samples and as
long as they're in gel tubes you're
using gel tubes uh not non-gel tubes
those samples are stable even if kept
outside because now the cells are
completely separated from the pseudonym
plasma the other important piece if you
cannot do that so for some clinics that
only send a few samples to the lab they
don't have processors who can spin the
samples with centrifuges on site then
what you need to do is to basically make
sure that your lock boxes that you're
keeping outside which are not insulated
or protected are moved indoors and kept
in a temperature controlled area so that
as long as you can give access to the
Courier of course basically to be able
to retrieve them without having the
samples impacted by prolonged exposure
to these extreme temperatures and it is
important for me to state that you know
the other factor that could be effective
if you're keeping those samples at room
temperature is basically
glucose may be affected so you may need
to if you're keeping samples of whole
blood you may need to collect glucose
into effect container the other thing is
if you can't do either point of care
testing may be the only option so it's
just the third backup if you really
can't do one or two above
fun fact about this this is not just a
problem for clinical chemistry when
you're doing testing it's also a bigger
problem for transfusion medicine because
the familial pseudohyperkalemia affects
about one in 500 patients from European
population and as blood donors those
patients if they're you know if their
blood is stored in a refrigerated uh set
up for a couple of hours their potassium
goes through the roof and then you're
transfusing those high levels of
potassium into neonates or large levels
to uh to to to other adult patients they
can cause cardiac arrest so it's very
important to be aware if a patient has
this condition and in some cases
screening for them before uh becoming a
blood donor so that was case one moving
to case two which is focusing on a
pediatric patient with uh unexplained
low carbon dioxide so in this case this
patient is a seven month old girl
presented to the Ebu the history of
diarrhea for the previous 24 hours but
was otherwise well blood was collected
from the Anaconda fossa for electrolyte
analysis so this was like a regular
Venus draw and the second sample was
collected two hours later
the initial blood sample for CO2 again
this is Venus uh so was 11 when the
reference interval was 23 to 30. so it
was very low which was concerning but it
wasn't inconsistent with the clinical
picture
so that second sample that they sent
they ran CO2 on that and that was
slightly high it was 18 millimoles per
liter so closer to normal but it
couldn't explain what's happening
clinically with the patient so they
reached out to the lab for an
explanation
so the lab looking at this noted it went
back and repeated the samples and
noticed that the initial samples
contained 0.3 millimeters in a floral
tubes well the second sample contained
two moles in a formal container so why
is this why is this important and why
would this happen so typically as
providers or as nursing staff or
phlebotomy staff you may look at a baby
and worry about drawing too much blood
right so you try to save as much blood
from the baby and you just try to
collect as low as you can unless you're
using pediatric tubes that can cause
issues as we were seeing in this example
so they basically went and used a 4ml
value container too but only do a little
bit and put them in that too so that can
cause issues the other thing is just
important to know that delay in analysis
can also affect CO2 but in this case the
sample arrived very quickly it was
within 30 minutes on it so it's not so
delay was not the big factor here so
what they decided was to investigate
this effect on what happens when you
underfill the tube significantly versus
doing it completely and how would that
affect your CO2 levels and and so what
they did was collected blood from
different volunteers and monitored uh
about over 240 minutes and these were
the results basically on the bottom end
you have the circle uh lines the circles
the filled circles that represent
basically a full tube or 4ml and you're
looking at how much CO2 you're losing
over time so as you go up the graph here
you're losing much more CO2 and as you
notice the trend is the less blood you
put in the tube over time even in 30
minutes for that 0.3 ml2 you've lost 30
percent of your over 30 of your CO2 so
the model of the story here is simple
you really need to use pediatric tubes
and collecting blood from pediatric
patients if you're using the adult tubes
those can be a problem and it's
important that you fill those blood
tubes completely to avoid air exposure
in the sample so for CO2 specifically
that can be a big problem uh so it's
very important to follow those two
recommendations before sending samples
to the laboratory and you should and on
the lab side you know we really should
consider injecting on the fill tubes
less than 50 before specifically CO2
analysis also the tubes should be
analyzed within one hour following
collection it's more important for CO2
if it's full it's a completely filled
too that it's one hour from actually
uncapping with you because as long as
the air exposure is minimal it will not
be an issue but you don't want to delay
too much and we will we shouldn't allow
as Laboratories add-on testing for
carbon dioxide which we add on testing
means you're basically allowing a
physician to add a test on an existing
tube which could have been a couple of
hours ago and it's already open for more
than a couple hours that will not be
acceptable for CO2 while we allow it for
other tests so that basically sums up
case two moving over to case three which
focuses on unexplained elevation and
lactate and in this case we have a 60
year old Hispanic man who was admitted
to general medicine service two days ago
with a diabetic foot infections and his
foot was hot red and quite swollen but
with a Malhotra still also that was a
necrotic highness of infection the foot
worsened over the next two days and he
was rushed to the or for a total
amputation
and and they ordered the lactate five
hours after surgery so this is after uh
that was addressed but the lactate level
was significantly elevated it was 10
millimoles per liter for reference the
reference interval for lactate is around
0.5 to 2.2 and if your value is greater
than four that is considered critical so
this was a highly critical result so the
lab modified Resonance of this variable
result
so this was puzzling because the patient
really was receiving antibiotics fluids
and surgery but the value was still high
so nothing seemed to address it and the
doctors rushed back to the room to look
at you know what could be causing this
you know lack of tissue perfusion so
they suspected you know sepsis that
could have been caused by the foot
infection but it was not important with
the clinical picture they just gave
additional fluids and ensured IV
antibiotics and then basically sent more
testing so they did routine Labs blood
gases chests X-ray and a repeat lactate
while they were waiting for those
results to come back they started
thinking of other scenarios you know do
amputations cause artifactual lactate
elevations could Global fall from the
Orbee the culprit what could be
explaining this consistently High
lactate level and then the lactate from
the recent analysis came back as 14. so
it was even higher than it was before
and moreover this new CDC the complete
workout companies have worked out they
basically uh Retreat for the patient was
odd patients leukocytosis has resolved
and the patient now has a knee so
basically all of a sudden the patient
has a has no longer has a high white
cell count and now that they have their
anemic so they started thinking about
this new data and suggested that you
know perhaps lactate elevation and back
pain could be a typical presentation of
an abdominal catastrophe so they ordered
the CT scan of the algorithm
meanwhile Mr business who's a
phlebotomist have concerns about the
technique that was used by the other
phlebotomist and wanted to draw the
sample herself the nurse at that time
was in clean and remembered you know
could this be caused by LR which is what
they were using you know to give the
patient fluids which is lactated ringers
and if you don't know lactated Rangers
is a mixture of sodium chloride sodium
lactate among other things and it is
used for replacing fluids and Health
Products and those who have low blood
volume or low blood pressure
so when they basically Drew Labs from
the arm opposing to the one where the IV
was attached the labs were normal
so in this case the lesson learned from
this is that you know it took days
several unnecessary procedures and eight
MDS working it up before resolving this
error that occurred as a result of the
proper collection technique and this is
what we call in laboratory Field IV
contamination so if you've had a could
happen with lactate could happen with
saline could happen with any anything
that you're attaching as an eye fluid
and then you're drawing a blood sample
from that arm or through that same line
without appropriately shutting it off
and flushing it when needed can cause
these issues so you'll have really wacky
results that don't fit the clinical
picture so what we have here and what I
would recommend for you at your own
institution is to make sure you have you
know policies to address to detect these
first of all and also the record to have
recommendations to the teams of what to
do when you see them and what you know
have best practice for making sure that
you are a collecting enough Dead Space
volume that will usually we say you have
to basically wait can collect this card
tube at least before collecting the
sample will be sent to the lab and then
we also say you should you know if you
can't get a reliable result from the IV
just avoid using the IV to draw the
blood sample go to the opposite arm of
the IV site if you can't draw below the
IV site and if unable to do that then at
least shut off the IV wait two minutes
collect the discard tube then send the
sample and we have ways of detecting
these in the lab and how we flag them
for our clinical teams using Delta
checks so we recently published a paper
that basically developed noodles to
better detect these so we can flag them
at a at a better rate
and that covers case three so we're
flying through these which is great we
still have three more cases before we
you know wrap up and talk about any
other questions you like but case four
focuses on this coordinate point of care
results and lab main lab glucose results
so in this case we have a patient who's
a 63 year old man with metastatic lung
cancer who was admitted for severe hip
pain and malaise with no other symptoms
reported the patient had erratic daily
morning plasma glucose concentrations
with several critical values that are
less than 40. so for reference you know
the reference interval for glucose is
usually 70 to 100 so these were kind of
significantly concerning like very very
low political uh however every time they
have a low critical glucose from the
main lab they would draw a finger stick
glucose and measure it using point of
Care by the patient's bedside and that
result comes back normal so you have a
Discord result between what the main lab
is saying for the for the hospital from
the hospital and then what what
basically the finger stick is saying
collected bedside
so which value is correct here do you
trust the finger stick or do you cross
the plasma glucose and why
so the recommendation is to always focus
on the clinical picture in this case the
patient had no symptoms of hypoglycemia
which for somebody with less than 40
that would be pretty obvious uh which in
so that indicates that the plasma
glucose is likely falsely low so what
can cause a falsely low plasma glucose
there are three common causes one is
delayed separation from cells so glucose
typically degrades at a rate of 10 per
hour so if the sample has kept as whole
blood and if you took a long time to get
it to the lab to be rad that can
basically your Google's values will be
falsely low now in this case we know
that did not happen the sample was
actually delivered to the lab within 15
minutes so it wasn't the delay
you know of course in terms of
separating the cells and running it so
leukocytosis is another big one so if
you have a lot of white cells in that
blood sample white cells just like red
cells also consume glucose so except
instead of your average 10 per hour
decrease you could have over 100
decrease per hour in terms of glucose
degradation so much much faster because
you simply have more cells eating
glucose that or consuming glucose that's
present in the sample or hypoperfusion
can be another issue that can cause
cause these typical like low results in
that specific area
however when we tested the patient's
white cell count due out leukocytosis we
found that they had over 30 000 cells
per microliter so that definitely is the
cause and it's a common phenomenon in
patients with non-small cell lung cancer
so especially in patients with with
cancer if you have a Cancer Clinic where
you draw blood samples it's extremely
important to be vigilant about this and
to make sure that either the sample is
run right away or that you're basically
you know your only option might be point
of care testing if you can't stabilize
it
and so in this case it's extremely high
wide cell count that and soon Google
goes much more rapidly and even a
15-minute delay in the sample will not
allow you to run to run it appropriately
so what can you do and one of the one of
the other suggestions is running the
sample but using a sodium fluoride tube
which is a great option to collect it
and send it to the lab so great top to
stabilize glucose by stopping the
glycolytic pathways so what happens if
you collect it in a great top tube
versus your lithium hepatine or Serum is
the you know you stop consuming glucose
you have slight degradation but then it
stops it so you can run that sample even
in several hours later and get a normal
result so and that's in this case what
it will solve this so what are the
recommendations for when dealing with
situations like this one
a immediately measured whole blood
glucose samples or separate them from
the cells when not possible so this is
also important for those you know if you
work in a clinic and you're sending
examples to the main lab really having a
centrifuge and the person who processes
those samples in your clinic was vital
for the quality of your results so if
you cannot achieve that then really the
only other option you'd have to
basically collect blood in a separate
tube for just glucose measurement which
is the great outdo unfortunately we
cannot measure the other tests that we
run on a comprehensive metabolic panel
or basic metabolic panel on the gray top
so that means you're going to have to
send two samples for for for every
patient you're trying to get this
measure done one would be for the rest
of the chemistry tests and one would be
for glucose if you do not have a
processor
and finally in patients with extremely
high white cell counts like some cancer
patients you know rapid analysis by
point of care devices may be preferred
uh or you're only often maybe sending
them again great updates as well would
work for this as before they be shown
so now moving to cases five and six
which are slightly different in that uh
I these are not patient focused and
these are problem focused and I use this
as an example because these are things
that we on the laboratory side often get
as feedback when you know there's a
problem with a certain test that we're
doing that our clinical partners are
seeing they can reach out class and say
hey we're seeing uh this issue or this
problem and we typically investigate and
try to address it in this example we've
received complaints
um of too many high calcium results so I
don't know if you get that uh you know
on the laboratory side or on the
clinical side do you do you notice this
with with some of your patients or a lot
of your patients all that matters so the
story here is that as a laboratory
director received a complaint from a
group of Physicians who recently joined
the health system and they were
concerned that they're seeing too many
abnormal high calcium results the
director requested data on the
percentage of high abnormal calcium
results by location so they can
investigate this further so typically
here it's a good idea to try to look at
data that helped understand the problem
and so in this case given that some
clinics were seeing this we thought like
it would be a good idea to basically
look at uh you know which what how much
are they seeing and and is that a
problem is it different from other sites
because again these are a group of
Physicians who recently joined so this
is the the data analyst and provided
this data uh for the health system but
excluded sites with less than 60
collections per month so we're only
focusing on the percent of high calciums
for each clinic but only for clinics
that have enough volume of these samples
so uh in this case you're seeing like
these are four clinics listed here that
met those criteria over 300 runs per
month and then the percentage of high
results you're seeing in all of these
outpatient clinics is 16 is around like
15 to 16 or 17 so the question that
would come up first is this a problem
uh in thinking through this and and
knowing in laboratory medicine the
Technically when we derive our reference
intervals for our patients it is based
on excluding five percent of healthy
individuals meaning two and a half
percent on the high end and two and a
half percent on the low end should flag
as high based on the normal way we
derive reference intervals so we stay
sensitive to diseases and can kind of
monitor things more closely so in this
case in an outpatient setting where you
don't typically expect because again
most of these are part of cmps so
they're not like specifically being
evaluated for hypercalcemia these are
not patients so a 16.8 is extremely high
uh as a as a flag versus what I would
expect is somewhere around three to five
percent max so that yes definitely this
indicates that you know there is some
issue that is happening and then looking
specifically at the clinic locations uh
I know the names probably don't mean
much to you but the PED stands for
Pediatric locations so three out of four
locations like pediatric locations and
the the fourth one also collects uh
pediatric examples but it's not just the
Pediatric location so what is happening
here and is that a clue to something
so the site was using a single reference
interval that was designed for adults in
the example here that's 8.8 to 10.2 as
provided by the manufacturer I will say
for you know providers who are surprised
by this most manufacturers do not revive
you graph pediatric reference intervals
for all that assay so not some
Laboratories you know they have no
option and simply validate the adult and
only list that others may try to derive
literature based reference intervals and
then verify them if they can although
simply like that's that may be
impractical and they might just decide
to to plug them in for that specific
assay if available but it is not
uncommon that many Labs do not yet use
pediatric reference intervals because
it's simply not provided for that assay
but it is important to say like recently
there's been a lot of studies that have
come out specifically eyesight the one
here which is from the from from Canada
that have recruited over 10 000 healthy
children to deny reference intervals for
major manufacturers like Roche uh who
use here and basically have published
all their data and we can basically
choose to use that and verify if
possible and if not most labs are trying
to implement these and trying to figure
out ways to verify but in this case what
they've shown is that for you know 1 to
17 years old that reference interval is
9.3 out of 10.6 and less than one year
old it goes even slightly higher to 11
on the high end so you have patience
pediatric patients that you who are
between 10.2 and 10.6 at least and 11 on
the on the less than one year old whose
result is actually normal for their age
group but would be flagging high if your
laboratory simply implemented the adult
changes only so this is very important
then to state that
you need to basically try to implement
pediatric ranges where you are if you
don't so if you're a provider
interpreting results for Pediatric
patients be extra careful and double
check that the reference interval
applied is not simply an adult range and
you may find that out by simply
contacting your lab director or your lab
provider to understand what they're
doing and how they're doing it
and I as I mentioned already assay
manufacturers may not provide that so if
you're a laboratory director of struggle
or struggling with that decision I would
say you should consult caliber studies
which are the best literature that we
have now there is a big push in the
United States to try to do these studies
as well in the US but so far Congress is
not approved spending for these and
there are a number of associations like
aacc the one part of that's actually
actively pushing Congress every year to
fund the CBC to allow us to to basically
do these pediatric studies so we have
more reliable efforts of also our
populations so far this has not happened
and so the one I would recommend using
for now if you haven't heard of it it's
called caliper and that's basically the
most reliable to date and it was
published in the last decade so a lot of
this is new and I wouldn't be surprised
if your laboratory is not using them
already but many are and they're moving
in that direction so I would highly
encourage you to consult caliber uh in
order to implement pediatric reference
intervals at your Institution
and so we're great on time and now we
can dedicate uh the rest of the time
focusing on everybody's favorite topic
which is hemolysis and I saved this for
last specifically because it is a big
one I will say it will take usually more
than one lecture to just focus on all
the things that would cause hemolysis
but the number one thing I will say no
your lab is not humanizing your samples
humongous can happen for a variety of
reasons that could include poorer
collection techniques and poor
Transportation techniques
and but there are some things that the
lab can do to help reduce the effects
also that you know when the reporting
results to you but predominantly we need
to work together to address these issues
and so I want to focus on two problems
at once here so adult emergency medicine
and the neonatal Intensive Care Unit so
we have something for adult EB and the
neonates and the NICU who are
complaining of high rates of hemolysis
and for those of you who are not
familiar which I doubt since the
majority of your laboratory
professionals hemosis looks like what we
are seeing in the picture below when we
separate the blood sample uh by spinning
it down you see you should see that
plasma look like number of the sample
label number one as you have more
hemolysis in the sample you start having
basically more cells of Lysine and
you're releasing more hemoglobin into
the sample along with a lot of other
things that can interfere with that
thing and so you see it gets slightly
more orange slightly more red and then
finally like you have severe hemolysis
which you see here good friend and so
how do we stop this
it's important to show to say for the Ed
there's different analytes that are
predominantly affected them for the NICU
for the Ed you typically see viewed
elevations in potassium and
we're actually not giving you that
result so all you get is essentially
sample hemalized and then you'd have to
read it all the sample same proponent
High sensitivity assets are more
susceptible to that level of
interference so that can be a problem
for the evening and they're always
contacting us about these two analytes
specifically for the NICU the one that
is more commonly affected is directly
open uh so I don't know if you could
relate on your side as a provider or uh
as a laboratory those are the most
common ones but basically it's important
to say that hemosis does affect things
differently and at different levels so
if you are getting a result for maybe
ASP or sodium on the same sample you
might not get potassium simply because
it's so much more sensitive and the most
sensitive element analyte that we have
is actually LBH so lactate the
hydrogenase but it's not as commonly
measured so it's not quite as much of a
problem as we see with potassium that's
more commonly needed
and again as I've already summarized the
problem is not you're allowed it's
basically a combination of collection
technique and transportation so what can
go wrong and how can we address it in
both areas but before we go there I do
want to say again there are some things
as I managed that your lab can do to
help with these uh thresholds so I first
of all manufacturers typically assess
the effective interference only using
one concentration and a ten percent
change for all analytes which is not
necessarily best practice a 10 change
for sodium means One Thing versus a 10
change for potassium or glucose so 10 in
sodium is going from 140 to 126. that's
not acceptable your thresholds for
sodium should be much tighter whereas
your thresholds for potassium may be
much can be looser because you know
going from a three to a 3.3 is not that
significantly different uh clinically at
least so it's important to remember that
those thresholds that we're getting from
manufacturers may not be the best for
clinical care so we need to re-evaluate
these as directors and make sure that at
least for those sensitive analytes they
are appropriate and so for those that
are sensitive what you can do and what I
recommend is re-evaluating and
establishing it at different
concentrations and using tiered
thresholds now what does that mean and
what does that look like so this is an
example for high sensitivity component
that was published from the Mayo Clinic
where they basically instead of using
one cutoff of hemolysis that the
manufacturer gives which is a hemolysis
index of a hundred so if you any any
values that are greater we lost index
greater than 100 which is what we use in
the lab to tell if that sample is
effective
would have been rejected in this case
you know by splitting it up and focusing
on areas you know lower concentrations
you have if it's less than eight it
would be 300 if it's 9 to 37 it would be
195. you know so it varies based on the
concentration because let's face it you
know you make it if troponin is
10 versus 15. but if it's
350 versus 330 is that really a big
change because right now you might be
rejecting them whereas clinically that
is important for the clinician to know
because you're not giving them any
results uh when when knowing that it's
that high alone is very useful for them
so I strongly recommend following this
approach for those sensitive analytes
and establishing criteria for change
which in this case they use mine like
Delta of two for the low end less than
eight and a Delta of four for the high
end
making sure that's appropriate and then
establishing new thresholds that change
by concentration we use these thresholds
in our lab the other example for
directly Ruben as well there's another
study that was presented by the
University of Iowa researchers who
basically did the same thing with direct
bilirubin and split them up you know by
concentration so for just so you know
for direct Billy manufacturer recommends
any change over an H index of 30 which
is very low for hemolysis should be
basically rejected because it causes a
significant change but what the
researchers have shown here really you
can be more prominent using more
reasonable criteria and by splitting
that up based on concentration so in
that case they would be reporting up to
140 for anything less than 0.5 which
would be hopefully the majority of
patients and then they would put a
disclaimer on the results if the results
are between 140 and 200 saying there may
be a change up to 10 so you as a
provider know that this result may be
slightly affected by hemolysis and then
if it's hemolysis over 200 they're
canceling so that we won't give you that
result because we know it's
significantly effective and it's not
going to be useful for you so this
approach which I like to call the
traffic light approach where if it's no
interference green release the results
but you've used reasonable thresholds to
decide what's green and then if there is
some interference slight level up to 10
let's say you can say okay the least the
result or the comment so in case they're
questioning it clinically they recognize
there might be some interference and
then read significant interference do
not release the result at all that
approach really helps you not eject too
many samples and actually still give
results that maybe clinically meaningful
for the provider to have so that's the
approach that we follow here and I
highly recommend on the laboratory side
at least to make sure you're using these
to flag samples if they need to be
flagged with a comment or flat out eject
them if they're too high instead of one
threshold to Simply reject
so we've talked about what the lab can
do now let's focus on the issues that
can happen in transportation and then
we'll get the collection quickly for for
any uh providers or phlebotomy teams or
nursing people to collect blood so if
they kind of get a sense of what needs
to happen there so for for
transportation we recognize that for the
NICU specifically uh I mean it does have
some effect for about patients as well
coming from the Ed but your pneumatic
tube system can be a major source of uh
hemolysis and that's simply because that
you know you're loading the samples in
these carriers that are traveling at
high g-forces through the laboratory so
the longer they're going uh through that
system and the more turns and twists you
can have significantly more hemolysis so
if you if your Ed is located very close
to the lab you may not have as many
issues but if you're further away over
the location that you're sending
examples further away you will have
issues so for the NICU what we found
helpful here for us is by padding the
tubes as you see in this picture with
home inserts those specific samples
coming from an EQ are basically
protected throughout Transportation so
by implementing this and using yellow
carriers specifically to designate these
as NICU carriers and they have these
hole inserts on them we were able to
significantly reduce the effects of
hemosis coming from that clinic however
the foreign were not a successful
initiative on the adult EV side simply
because they would they send too many
tubes to only fit like this wide form
and search and so this would not work
because you increase your traffic
significantly if they're going to send
each tube in a carrier so for the NICU
it works because we don't get that much
volume but for the Ed it would be next
to impossible to use this so sometimes
if you're having repeated problems for
some patients your only option may be to
try to avoid using the United group
system to get your best chance at
getting the result for that patient so
you may often hear the lab asking you
please lock the sample through the
laboratory together also that patient if
you keep repeatedly having issues it
simply doesn't mean that this is
affecting all patients but it just gives
you the best chance of getting a result
because again hemolysis is cumulative so
trying to reduce the effects of
Transportation so that you kind of make
up for that difference and may be able
to get a result so now
in the last few minutes I'll just say
collection is a whole world of things
that can happen so I just tried to focus
on through practical recommendations
that I can ask you as somebody who's
collecting blood samples should be aware
of one is a study that came out of
Cleveland Clinic who is basically
evaluated the effect of using smaller
tubes so they went from six milliliter
tubes for collecting one for DB to two
milliliter tubes uh and and what they
noticed in that period what I'm showing
you is that him also straight on on the
beginning in 2013 was around 14
and that shows you the Baseline but then
when they tested using the smaller tubes
that dropped to around two to three
percent and then they basically went you
know that was considered a successful
pilot but then they needed to get
obviously supply chain on board and then
uh implemented so you see a post test
period that went back up only went back
up to the regular size tubes and then
that dropped significantly when they
finally implemented the use of these
smaller tubes so even for adults using
smaller tubes can be significantly
helpful to reduce the effects of
hemolysis and that happens we think
because of two mechanisms One is using
the smaller tube means that you're
basically drawing less blood so there's
less the travel in the tube but also the
main reason is because the larger tubes
have higher vacuum than them most
vacutainers contain a higher amount of
vacuum and they would hire a vacuum
you're pulling the cells through the
needle much faster they're so going
through that faster rate they could be
shearing the cells as they're getting
the larger heat so using those smaller
tubes there's less vacuum therefore less
force on the cells as they are drawn
into the tube and being collected so the
recommendation here is definitely switch
to the smaller tube size if you can as
long as you know that's also compatible
with your automation line so the one
thing to check is make sure that your
lavatory can handle that switch and
those samples can be run on on your your
automation line the other key factor
here is also this is unpublished data
from our lab being done by our postdoc
document who basically quickly looked at
fill volume and the effect that has on
the tube now we've already talked about
fill volume for carbon dioxide same
thing happens actually with hemolysis if
you're collecting less blood in a larger
tube and you're not filling it all the
way as this data suggests you know low
means less than 25 blood in the tube
versus partial is less than is between
25 to 75 and full is what we was over 75
percent of the tube is full you have
less hemolysis uh when you're collecting
full tubes the reason we think that
happens is as already mentioned
the beginning part of the tube is where
the highest vacuum is so the first
portion of the blood that you collect
will experience the maximum amount of
hemolysis and as you continue to collect
the vacuum is dropping because it's
filling so what then happens is there's
less and less and less force over time
so then if it's it's sort of like
brewing coffee where if you pull that
coffee pot too early when you've only
gotten the first Parts filled that's the
most concentrated part and that that's
why that tastes very uh dark and and
bitter right so they don't like leave it
till the end because that's when it
belows the same principle applies to it
if you're under filling a tube you're
basically having the highest amount of
hemolysis you need to fill it completely
to dilute that out so you're able to get
a more reliable resulting sample so the
main message here for hemolysis then is
essentially try using smaller tubes and
make sure those are filled completely
and I will not go into there's plenty of
more things that can cause it but I'm
just going to keep it practical for now
and at least ensure that those are too
simple hopefully changes you can
Implement that would help your hemolysis
so these are the full recommendations
for the other things that I also haven't
talked about for hemolysis essentially
we're talking about transitioning to
smaller size tubes and we said we must
fill them all the way I would also
recommend using vac retainers instead of
sitting just to draw blood I know this
is practice where they basically draw
blood through syringes and then put them
in a vacuum cleaner too that is bad
simply because blood is flowing through
that needle twice once in the syringe
and once back out into the vacuum you
have more chance of hemolysis when you
do that and that draw from a syringe
also depends on the operator going too
fast and do hard and you're gonna you're
gonna hemolize the sample so you really
need to be careful if that's the only
option you're doing and to draw slowly
but if you can avoid it all together do
not do it also avoid growing blood
through IV lines a straight stick is
preferred so not using that and collect
serum instead of plasma and walk through
the sample to the if to the lab of
hemolysis to continue to persist so with
that I get to the final slide which is
my somebody going back over everything
we've learned today and the points I
want you to leave with for case one for
potassium centrifuge samples quickly and
make sure lock boxes are in a
temperature controlled environment for
bicarbonate use pediatric tubes when
needed and ensure that the samples are
filled all the way and ran within the
hour for lactate or other issues that
could happen for the cause IV
contamination with other analytes as
well avoid growing samples from the IV
line or ensure appropriate flushing
prior to collection Implement Delta
checks in the lab for glucose process
samples immediately or use fluoride
tubes for calcium Implement pediatric
reference intervals for all assays
and hemolysis Implement tiered
thresholds in the lab protect during
transport collect blood in smaller tubes
but fill them completely and avoid using
syringes or drawing from an IV walk the
sample to the lab if necessary to avoid
those Transportation issues that can
happen in the narrative system and
that's basically my talk again there's
plenty of more this content that will
get available on my YouTube channel I
would encourage you to check that out if
that's of interest and uh with that I
also would like to get a sense of how
useful did you think this was as we
transitioned to the Q a feel free to
answer this and give me a more feedback
also will be available through the
survey that will be provided at the end
for comments thank you for your time and
I'm happy to take any questions at this
stage
thank you Joe for your informative
presentation
um so we got that pull up and we will
now start the live q a portion of the
webinar so if you have any questions
you'd like to ask please do so now just
click on the ask a question box located
on the far left of your screen and we'll
answer as many of your questions as we
have time for
all right so let's get started so
um one of the first questions I see is
we have a lot of questions coming in
that's awesome
um so this one says the majority of
Sarah are stored in a freezer this means
results could be questionable if the
values are high and this means the test
could be immediate without exposure to
low temperature do you have any comment
on that
absolutely so that is an excellent
question basically Sam majority of
samples are stored and declarified in
the refrigerator at least for clinical
units not freezer and usually we store
them ideally after separation from cells
right so when you've when you've spun
the sample down and there's a gel
separating the plasma from the cells
that sample is protected and potassium
will not change even if that sample is
stored in the refrigerator
the problem exists if the sample is
stored as whole blood so if you take a
sample that's old blood and you store it
in the refrigerator and I want to be
clear longer than three hours you will
have issues with potassium it will
slightly start to increase but then in
some of those patients that are I
mentioned specifically today families
even one hour of old one storage
refrigerated is a problem so yes it is
not ideal but you won't recognize it
except for those specific patients if
you're swallowing it as whole blood as
long as you don't store it more than two
hours so in a nutshell most samples
clinically are stored refrigerated after
separation from cells if you are keeping
them as whole blood you don't want to
keep them that way for more than two
hours
awesome thank you so much
um the next question I have here says
great talk
um why would a serum sample be better
for l d h oops excuse me then plasma
nope well excellent question so
that typically we think is related to
primarily Transportation so see them
what we found is for any hemoly sample
so I just want to start by saying we
ought to primarily plasma lab as well so
we send lithium Appleton from the Ed
however when we see these issues with a
hemolysis we we sometimes recommend that
they collect a serum sample instead and
walk it to the lab and the reason why we
think serum can be more productive from
hemolysis is because of the the
basically the one when you coagulate see
it in that clock that form the clotting
process
is can be protective because what
happens with the clot is it holds all
the cells in place we think and then
when you spin down essentially it
removes all of the cells and then you
can run it but throughout that uh time
when they're held by the clock they're
not lysing as much versus a plasma
sample that could be and we actually
just published a paper on that showing
that a serum tube is more protective
during uh Transportation by a pneumatic
tube system but it has to be fully
clotted before being transported so for
that purpose we use the rapid cm2 which
is the orange top tubes uh and show that
basically if you send those alongside a
plasma sample the orange top tube is
protective and it has lower levels of
hemolysis we think it's purely
mechanical where basically they're
protected by the plot during
transportation but again it's still you
know it's still an area that we're
studying we think that it wouldn't it
wouldn't be helpful if the primary
issues you're seeing are with collection
and I need to be clear about that so if
you don't have any issues with the
pneumatic tube system in transportation
a cm2 may not significantly help
awesome thank you and the next question
that I see come up is how would you
expect hemolysis to impact the co-aux
Symmetry measurements not sure if I
pronounced that right
yeah so for co-oximetry specifically
um
so I have not come across that because I
don't oversee blood gas testing here so
I would have to pass on this one I
apologize but like it's not something I
would see here and um I I wouldn't know
the answer to that question
okay thank you
um and the next one I have what are some
tips for dealing with lipomic turbid
samples and how do you use libemic index
in which instrument manufacturer lip
epic index do you use
so we use we're primarily a large
customer here for our main testing so we
use their L index and their thresholds
and for libemia it's typically more
straightforward for us because we simply
Ultra fuse the sample so we use an ultra
centrifuge to spin down the lipid layer
and basically take the fraction that's
then now remaining the plasma and serum
and then run that so we don't have any
issues with like beam examples because
we Ultra centrifugal
great thank you
um the next one I have what is your
hemolysis rate for newborn babies what
is the average H index for hemolyzed
sample in newborns
so that is an excellent question so
before we basically
implemented the the change that we did
we were seeing as high as uh 12 of the
samples were rejected in the NICU once
we implemented the change what we
basically used the foam insert that
dropped down to around three percent
that's for total rejection so sometimes
you all you some you may be flagging
samples still based and commenting and
like releasing a result but at least
total rejection significantly though and
there are published to determine I think
Mayo Clinic also did a study where they
did uh evaluate those effect in an EQ
and they show like uh something around
three to four percent is normal uh in
the NICU
okay and the next one I'm seeing does a
syringe for collection have an effect on
the hemolysis
absolutely so that can have an effect so
the recommendation here is to use
usually around 18 to 20 uh gauge size
needles for collecting one although
sometimes we recognize in some of those
difficult States like cancer patients uh
you may have to use a smaller bore size
which can cause issues but yes the
definitely that has been documented to
have an effect
okay and then the next one I see here
um
not the form of question but of note
potassium result in Serum is higher than
in plasma
you have a comment on that that is good
yes so that is correct I mean we know
that in most patients Serum is about 0.3
uh millimoles per liter higher than uh
in plasma however you know your
reference interval should reflect that
if you're using serum as well so in some
places they use different reference
intervals if you're collecting serum
versus collecting plasma for that reason
others just use a combined range but
again the differences we're trying to
solve here a 0.3 change is not
clinically significant this only matters
if you have patients with significantly
high platelet counts so patients with
thrombocytopenia you cannot or
thrombocytosis you cannot collect
pseudonym samples for those patients
because their potassium would be through
them so yes and some you know it's a
very difficult uh analyte to deal with
in some cases plasma is better like in
patients with thrombocytosis but in the
last see them sometimes may be better if
you're seeing analysis issues even
though that it may be 0.3 higher 0.3 is
not a clinically significant change
great thank you
um next one do you have any
recommendations with regards to
transporting urine specimens to an
ulterior site where it will not be
analyzed before at least three hours
enter Hospital transport
so your instability for each analyte can
differ depending on the additives that
you include so it really depends on what
you're testing and
um how long your your collecting it
before sending it to the lab some Labs
do like given acidification when they
receive them it really depends on the
analyte one recommendation I have if you
want to check what is best for stability
to buy different analytes I really
recommend you go to Mayo Clinic's
website they have and look specifically
under your instability they have a whole
table in the nice PDF file for every
analyte the different additives that
make them stable so you just have to
make sure that you're collecting in the
right like the in the jug with the right
additive so that it makes it stable for
the longest period of time possible but
that will vary by analyte
okay great thank you
um next one in the case where
electrolytes are requested every four
hours is it advisable to take from a
central line to minimize pain or
peripheral blood sample will be best
and again that's that's the common issue
right that's why people commonly collect
from from IV lines to try to avoid
sticking the patient every time again it
can be safe to do that if you've done
appropriately certainly if you you again
you're you're basically shutting off the
IV you're waiting a couple of minutes if
you need to and then discard the tube
then send the tube to the lab and you
don't see any issues that look abnormal
then it shows that it's okay so you can
try to do that but when you have issues
that's what I want to get to when you
start seeing these results that are
inconsistent with the clinical picture
because what you typically see is could
be a dilution of all analytes not
associated with the IV and an increase
or or a normal uh concentration for the
analytes that are being infused so if
you see that it is important to
basically verify it uh by taking another
sample from the opposite arm uh or just
to make sure that it's not before you
take any action on it so it's not love
artifact
thank you the next one I have does
drawing patients with butterflies or
straight needles have a higher risk of
hemolysis
so I that's an excellent question so
with collection again we've seen some
conflicting reports but uh more people
are recommending straight needles I have
not seen that at our location I will say
it is something that really depends on a
lot of techniques so more people
recommend state sticks but also
recognize it's impractical and the
effect that's coming from that may be
minimal meaning that in the big scheme
of things butterfly versus uh is stick
as long as you're not using very long
lines in between again these can
increase that because of the travel
I would say like you're you're likely
okay so
um
it's not it's these based on the studies
I've seen at least these are not major
contributors they think those look
slightly better
thank you so much we have time for about
one or two more questions next one I
have to you Ultra centrifuge all samples
or only lipumic samples and at what
level of leukemia do you use scent Ultra
centrifuge and then it says ultrasound
diffuse does not help with the
um turbidity caused by lipid or
lipoprotein factors other than high
triglycerides the lopemic index
correlates poorly with triglyceride
levels
all correct so to begin do we alter fuse
all samples no we don't we only alter a
few samples that trigger the lipinic
index for every specific analyte so for
example the rectum nirubin has a
lithiumic index of 100 sodium has a
lithium index of 700. so if a sample is
B is is B you know trying to get
directed a little bit if it's above 100
original Ultra Fusion if it's above 700
then we can also order for sodium so it
depends on every analyte and you have a
clear table with these guidelines uh to
answer the other piece of the question
was regarding uh the correlation with
um triglycerides and how it wouldn't
resolve anything other than high
triglycerides I would I would I I agree
uh however there is still a generally
useful metric for detecting those
samples that can deviate significantly I
can tell you from our lab we even see
issues where an L index is falsely High
uh because of uh other components that
interfere with that index like uniform
so we've seen in some patients who you
take the sample the L index is let's say
around 250 then you all refuge and that
L index doesn't change it's still 250.
that is usually a sign that you have
pseudo-lipemia and for those samples
we've recently reported a case where you
basically can release the results
because it's not really a liability
interference the sample color is usually
green and that is the wavelength that
the like India index is checked on so
those are other factors that could
affect it but yes certainly it's not a
perfect Market but it's the best we have
to try to spot those samples that we
have issues with and yes anything
exceeding that threshold fluid Ultra
fuse
awesome thank you we have time for one
more question
um how would hemolysis be expected to
affect co-oximetry measurements
I think that already came up and I
addressed it
uh let's see did it okay
and we can move on to another one um
this one says
I see the one I like on calcium I think
they're saying like five percent is in a
normal population but in the hospital
people are six sixteen percent is okay
yeah so to clarify these are from
outpatient centers so they're not these
patients that I mentioned for calcium 16
these are patients who are not in the
hospital they're being checked maybe for
other reasons they're sending a
comprehensive metabolic panel that
includes calcium or the basic metabolic
panel for us also includes calcium so 16
in a hospital may be a problem which is
why I wouldn't have worried about it if
it was these patients were in the
hospital but outside of the hospital
that is huge and that was directly
linked to these pediatric patients that
I mentioned
okay thank you so much and thank you to
our audience for those questions
um and thank you for your time today and
your important research we would also
like to thank lab roots and our sponsor
radio meter for underwriting today's
educational webcast before we go I'd
like to thank the audience for joining
us today and they're interesting
questions questions we did not have time
for today or those submitted during the
on-demand period will be addressed by
the speaker via the contact information
you provided at the time of registration
and this webcast can also be viewed on
demand lab Roots will alert you via
email when it's available for replay we
encourage you to share that email with
your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event until next time thank
you so much everybody bye-bye
thank you